Westwood one lead Thursday night
football analyst and a Hall of Fame
finalist again former Jags tackle
Westwood one radio all the action the
NFL divisional playoffs this weekend
coverage kicks off for Eastern on
Saturday 12:30 on Sunday and Tony will
be in Foxborough Chargers Patriots with
AI an eagle that's it one o'clock on
Sunday good morning Tony how are you
good morning I was down I was enjoying
the banter back and forth about the Cody
party honor award the Today Show I was
good banter and I agree I mean we start
giving awards way for but not doing your
job is an interesting tactics I feel if
you were a Bears he made of Cody porky
and he's going on The Today Show you
know the fact that he missed the kick
I'd be like it's okay like it's part of
the game like we all made plays during
the game it's unfortunate but that's the
thing that stands out but like it's okay
it's over let's move on I don't need to
see you on The Today Show
it's like too much because guess what
the fact that the left guard got beat
and gave up a sack you know he handled
the right with his head up high and you
know in this still alive okay great
we're gonna give him award or the drop
pass for the Miss K or whatever it's too
much I would be like just go away
disappear I don't want to see any of you
people until we start OTAs it's uh you
know it's too much I don't mean to see
him what are you doing why are we giving
trophies or like it's like the old so I
hate like two sports now everyone gets a
trophy let's give everyone a trophy just
for showing up it's ridiculous but I I
I'm still shocked that nobody has
embraced the actual truth is that the
kick got blocked it got tipped and
everybody yeah he missed it he missed it
blocked it it does not matter they lost
a game what's why are we talking about
it all right what kind of weather gear
are you packing for
sir you're headed to New England what
are you preparing for the good news is
you know that when I start with Westwood
I was on the sidelines all the time in
the playoffs I've moved my way
and so it was it was absolutely hell
going into England it was trees it'd be
visible now I'm in the booth so of a
heater I'm not you know so I'll still
have jeans on and I sure you know a
heavy coat maybe a you know some gloves
but I'll be very comfortable they have
clam chowder in the booth so coffee I
will not be suffering like our sideline
reporter but would you you know the
offensive lineman and I go back to the
coldest game ever played when the
Bengals played the Chargers in the
playoffs and those offensive linemen
came out and they had no sleeves and I
went wow did you send a message to the
Chargers does that still work in the NFL
I love it I never wore sleeves now it's
my best story about no sleeves is when I
was playing with the gym we played
Cincinnati's ironically up there and it
was like - 13 windchill and I remember
going on the field pregame with no
sleeves and it hurt it was painful I
think it was like me and a couple
offensive lineman and Kenan and Kenan
Mark our mark our del the writers here
were never wore sleeves and it's
miserable
I mean it's so uncomfortable you're
sitting near your cold bowl time you're
not even thinking about the game you're
cold so we walk in and I'm actually for
the first time of my career considering
putting sleeves on before the game and I
look over Kenan to put his sleeves on
I'm like you know maybe I should do it
and I'm sitting there thinking about it
and Tom Coughlin's the walks up to me
and he goes hey you need to put some
sleeves on it's gonna be cold out there
that's dangerous at that moment I looked
at him and said there is no bleeping way
I'm putting some sleeves on if you're
gonna tell me to do it I'm not doing it
I got a bunch of Vaseline but Vaseline
all over my body walked out there was no
solution it wasn't very smart because I
don't think it's like I don't think it
intimidated anybody I don't think made
anyone think he's like so scary like I
don't want to play him now because he
has no sleeves I think they looked at me
is that he is an idiot if he has no
sleeves on and he's colder than we are
so we're better off so but it's it's
it's something mentally I never warm I
don't think I ever would and I have no
idea how I handled it because now I'll
go up living in Florida New England and
I will be cold the entire time complain
the entire time but that brings up
important point that we always look at
that you know the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
could never win a game when the
temperature was under like you know 40
degrees or something they were famous
for not being able to hear the Chargers
coming East and how do you prepare for
that weather if you're the Chargers
where it's not going to have a real
effect on your game plan yeah well you
can't prepare for because practice wise
you're not going to be able to you know
replicate the situation now the other
thing is I'm a firm believer it's a lot
of the reasons Tampa number one under 40
is because they weren't very good either
you know good teams like everyone says
it's hard to win on the road not if
you're good like if you're good you win
on the road but the Chargers are nine
and L outside of Los Angeles County this
year they're a good football team but
twelve them for I don't think they're
gonna what they're not gonna walk into
Foxborough and Gillette Stadium
oh my gosh were on the road it's cold I
mean this is a veteran group they're a
good football team I mean you can't
you're not gonna you know they're not
gonna go find a way in Los Angeles to
make it 30 degrees as we practice but I
don't think that matters when you're
when you have veteran guys who are
mentally tough this was a mentally tough
team Dan I don't think it has anything
to do with the game at all talking to
Tony Boselli Hall of Fame finalist again
he'll be working the Westwood one game
the Chargers and the Patriots do you
have any relationship with Brady
I do not my relationship with Tom Brady
is he after when I was doing sideline
wants you know we'd interview them after
they were always gone the Super Bowl and
you know I started interviewing and I
had conversation with them for whatever
reason one time I went up to interview
am I supposed to interview him
afterwards and he's walked by I said not
today
that was my extended my relationship he
just kind of gave me the Heisman a long
time behind and now understood how
everyone in the media felt when an
athlete looks at you and says you are
not good enough to talk to you I have no
time for you I'm moving on so that's the
extent the relationship I have I mean
I've said hi to him a couple times but
wait you're a Hall of Famer in enjoy
this was this is creed this is what I
was only a semifinalist so
all right maybe the matter no thanks I
gotta go on a mic all right
I got the producer my ear going how did
the Chargers win this game oh gosh I
think you know you won
you got any time on the road in the
playoffs you can't get overwhelmed early
and I don't think they will that's
proven that they can come from behind
that it can say that in Pittsburgh this
year I think Melvin Gordon is the key
they got to get the run game going a
little bit Philip Rivers has not played
great the last few weeks their offense
has not been great they've turned the
ball over they're not scoring points
they're putting a lot of pressure on the
defense and so I think I ain't getting
the run game going with Melvin Gordon
will kind of free some things up for
offensively and then defensively
whenever you play the Patriots it's
about tackling these routes I think it's
so important whether it's Edelman
running those option routes underneath
you know right out of the backfield they
kill you they think and dunk it'll
spread you out and especially now that
you know they don't have that real
threat over the top
Patterson can do it a little bit but
he's more of a return guy I think
defensively they got to come up and
tackle if they tackle well and you know
keep everything in front of them I think
though they'll be okay I think to be
very is the best game of the weekend in
my mind because I think they're very
evenly matched teams and and I joked
about Tom Brady earlier here you know
the gray he is the greatest quarterback
to ever play the game in my mind and
watching him and what he's doing at his
age and the combination of him and
Belichick is just I mean every time I
can watch it and having played and play
a high level and being on around great
players dan I'm amazed I'm literally a
made for I watch him play the game he is
that good whatever skills physically are
diminishing because of his age his mind
in this competitive nature or over the
top and him and beljac together boy it's
a it's quite a match I think it to be a
great game how would you handle Aaron
Donald
I would slide to him every day and
double him every play I would do what
the Bears did on Sunday night when they
basically took him out and that's and
kids zero pressures eaten nothing
and I would just say listen we are
doubling him because if he is single
blocked he's a he's a menace there's
very few people that have seen will
block them this year and done
effectively over 60 minutes so you slide
the center to him every time and you
just say listen wherever it is we're
sliding to him we're going to double him
you tell the guard to over set him and
so if he's gonna beat he's gonna come
back inside and work towards the center
and then then it's the challenge of the
Rams and and Wade Phillips is like all
right how do we get a more single block
we got to you know bring the safety over
there maybe bring the safety a little
bit to create one-on-one situations the
will linebacker to his side and blitz
him so you can try to get Aaron Donald
101 because when he is his win
percentage is way over 50% so there's a
pride aspect though to this Tony that
isn't there part of you that says you
know hey I got him or or do you are you
you have to put your ego to the side and
say let's be smart here I'm gonna need
help on him yeah I think the player you
want to say I got them and at the same
time you got to be honest with yourself
and it's this is where coaching said
yeah you might think you happen but
we're going to make sure we got them and
so players yeah as a player you got this
I'm gonna win 2-1 alum down but that's
the coach's job and in understanding
what a player can and cannot do and
sometimes there's just guys that are hot
and Aaron Donald is the best pass
rushing defensive lineman in the NFL I
mean he is that he's just better than
everybody else right now
and because of that you have to game
play them you want your players saying I
have them like as if I was playing
against my back no I can handle it
one-on-one but then all of a sudden the
coach better say you know what I'm the
game plan and I'm going to have a scheme
in place so he doesn't ruin our day
because he's the type of guy was in the
room today
well Jason Peters had Khalil Mack
one-on-one and I thought that that was
really impressive and he took Clos Mack
out of that game
I think Jason Peters is one of the left
tackles in this generation that is so
overlooked
underappreciated he is as good as any
left tackle who played in the last 1012
years he's one my guy favorite guys to
watch he's physical he's tough he's a
good run blocker and he's a is an
amazing pass blocker as well I thought
he did great job of Khalil Mack it was a
great one-on-one matchup no and so and
so if you're asking yeah if you have
Jason if you have a Jason Peters type
player guard do you feel better about
the one-on-one matchup sure no so if
it's the Cowboys you know with Zack
Martin and you say well I like Zack
Martin Martin against against Aaron
Donald okay
then maybe you want to slide as much the
problem is they also know that and they
aren't dollars on the line up on the
left guard instead of the right guard
yeah so there are certain players you
know offensive as an offensive lineman
that you say we can we trust him but
there's not very many of those guys when
you when you say it's Aaron Donald who
was the scariest guy that you faced I
know John Randle yeah John was different
but we had yeah he played like I played
against employees once when he was at
his prime and once at the end and when
used in his prime up in Minnesota he was
because he was short fast powerful I
mean I just it was a miserable day so
but I don't think there's no one wearing
scared me I remember I probably the most
nervous I was before I knew any better
and it was my first year my second year
in the NFL we're playing it was the
playoff game against Bruce Smith and I
remember thinking going into that game
and he was Defensive Player of the Year
I'm watching him I'm like oh my gosh
this guy's a monster and I was a
second-year player so I watched him when
I was in college and he was Bruce Smith
and I remember going into the week and
we were game planning and Kevin Gilbride
are off it's coordinator and the Mike
majors our offensive lineman coach and
there was no game plan for me and I kept
on sitting there thinking like what do
we do it and I'm like you're like I
guess like sooner or later they're going
to come today we're going to slide to
them we're going to chip or and put it
back over there and all week no one said
anything and I'm watching film I'm like
okay maybe they know something I don't
and and the night
before the game we're getting ready for
it and Kevin told by student final prep
and he said they're talking says okay
yeah we know this is five minutes before
the meetings over
we know tony has a tough matchup in this
Bruce Smith I'm like well I'm glad
someone's acknowledging it finally and
so hey nature on nature means is the
back and he says hey if you get a chance
every once in a while when you're going
out just take a look but make sure you
get to your routes - and I remember go
to bed going that's our game plan for
the Player of the Year and and I was so
nervous during that game and I remember
that I mean then you get on the field
then it was just a football game and
play it and block them and in afterwards
a member talking they're like whoa we
just game plan was you were in a block
them I'm like think of a back-up at
least if it didn't work and and that's
it so yeah there's I guess there's
certain guys you trust you know Zach
Martin's one Jason Peters just another
offensive lineman I would trust there's
there's a handful guys out there but
Aaron Donald man there's not many guys
have blocked in 101 good stuff safe
travels Tony and if we don't talk to you
before you get the news about the Hall
of Fame
good luck hopefully you get that call
maybe I'll see you up in Atlanta for the
week if you're gonna be there from the
four week yeah that'd be great
and bring your hip there all week bring
your Hall of Fame jacket
thank you Tony edge Tony was selling for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]